[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
nitri Sirin schönen guten Abend
Wintersport später mit dir Christin und
segeln guten Abend und wir starten die
Sendung mit einer offenen Frage in
Berlin hier sind unsere Themen
wie weiter im Verteidigungsministerium
Gerüchte um den Rücktritt von Christine
Lambrecht verdichten sich das Kanzleramt
schweigt weiterhin
Suche in den Trümmern rettungskräfte
bergen in dem von Russland attackierten
Wohnblock in niepro weitere Tote finden
aber auch noch Überlebende
und Absturz in Nepal eine
Propellermaschine zerschellt beim
Landeanflug am Himalaya Flughafen von
Okara mindestens 68 Menschen sterben
[Musik]
wie weiter im Verteidigungsministerium
nachdem sich seit Freitagabend Hinweise
auf einen baldigen Rücktritt von
Christine Lambrecht verdichten stellt
sich immer lauter die Nachfolgefrage aus
dem Kanzleramt bis dato kein Kommentar
Kanzler Scholz und Ängste vertraute
sollen sich wie es heißt in der Sache
austauschen zum Stand der Dinge Frank
Buchwald noch Licht im Kanzleramt der
Chef so heißt es in Berlin hinter
vorgehaltener Hand Berater in kleinem
Kreis über das Schicksal von Christine
Lambrecht noch ist die
Verteidigungsministerin zwar im Amt ihr
Rücktritt gilt jedoch als ausgemacht der
SPD-Chef aber hält sich bedeckt ich
kommentiere Zeitungsartikel nicht aber
in einer Sache können Sie im Grundsatz
ausgehen das was wir als SPD zu
entscheiden haben das entscheiden wir
geschlossen mit dem Bundeskanzler
zusammen mit der Parteiführung mit dem
Fraktionsvorsitzenden und wir verkünden
Dinge dann wenn sie zu verkünden sind
Stiefel Panzer und flektan das war wohl
nie die Welt der Christine Lambrecht
Verteidigung aber viel Leben die SPD und
es muss deine Frau sein wegen der
Parität nun jedoch so die Opposition
sollte Scholz nach anderen Kriterien
entscheiden
jetzt muss es um Sachkompetenz gehen
jetzt braucht das
Bundesverteidigungsministerium jetzt
braucht die Bundeswehr eine Person an
der Spitze die mit Kompetenz und
Herzblut die Aufgaben angeht aus der
Koalition kommen ähnliche Signale Sarah
Nanni verteidigungsexpertin der Grünen
ließ wissen es gehe nun vor allem um
eine schnelle Entscheidung nicht um
Parität ähnlich argumentiert FDP Vize
Kubicki der Bundeskanzler sollte das für
Deutschland Sicherheit wichtige
Verteidigungsministerium nicht unter
paritätischen Gesichtspunkten nach
Geschlechtern sondern nur nach Kompetenz
besetzen
so gerät die Suche nach einer neuen
Spitzenkraft für die Bundeswehr für den
Kanzler zum Balance sagt
Chuck unterlab energy Scholz und die SPD
halten sich sehr bedeckt was hörst du in
Berlin
ja momentan ist es ganz schön schwierig
hier in Berlin überhaupt irgendetwas zu
hören denn alle die es wissen müssen
sind praktisch abgetaucht und man kriegt
nur sehr wenige Menschen ans Telefon
oder mal per SMS zu greifen und da kann
man dann raus hören zumindest dass alle
auf eine baldige Klärung hoffen und auch
damit rechnen aber in welcher Form das
ist eben unklar typisch für Scholz wäre
es die nächsten Schritte in einem sehr
kleinen Kreis abzusprechen und im
Interview mit Lars Klingbeil haben wir
ja gerade schon gehört wie ein solcher
Kreis eventuell aussehen könnte aber
offizielle Bestätigungen gibt es
überhaupt nicht das Gespräch mit Lars
kling weil dass wir eben aufgezeichnet
haben das ist in der im Grunde genommen
sehr interessant weil man da sehen kann
wie vorsichtig sich die Partei Spitze
momentan ausdrückt und wie sie in dieser
Angelegenheit kommuniziert aber
konkretes rauszubekommen bleibt
schwierig danke
gleich wieder mehr dazu nämlich gleich
auch immer Anschluss an unsere Sendung
in Berlin direkt
auch der Druck auf Deutschland schnell
Leopard Kampfpanzer an die Ukraine zu
liefern steigt aber vor allem bei der
Schnelligkeit da werden Zweifel laut der
konzernschef des Leopard Herstellers
rein Metall Pub Ärger wie es in der Bild
am Sonntag daraufhin dass man etwa ein
Jahr für die Instandsetzung Alter
Leopard 2 Panzer brauche in die Ukraine
die Russland gestern mit Angriffen
überzogen hatte mit Luftschlägen gegen
die kritische Infrastruktur in vielen
Regionen und mit einem Angriff auf
Zivilisten in nipro dort zerstörten
Marschflugkörper einen großen Wohnblock
bislang gibt es laut Behörden mindestens
25 Todesopfer und mehr als 70 verletzte
irgendwo unter den Trümmern wohl noch
viele Vermisste aus der Ukraine Tim
Krüger
die Luftaufnahmen vom Einschlagsort des
russischen marschflugkörpers sind
apokalyptisch die Hilfskräfte versuchen
verschüttete aus den Trümmern zu retten
die Zahl der Opfer aber steigt Stunde um
Stunde Angehörige sind verzweifelt
warum habt ihr ihn getötet ihr seid
früher in unsere Stadt gekommen und wir
haben euch als Gäste empfangen als
normale Menschen als normale Verwandte
was habt ihr meinem Sohn angetan ihr
Schurken
und doch werden viele tatsächlich
gerettet am Nachmittag noch Bergen die
Helfer eine Frau Leben aus dem
zerstörten Gebäude unter den vielen
Toten aber ist ein 15-jähriges Mädchen
unter den Verletzten allein sieben
Kindern ich bin einfach nur geschockt
ich hätte nie gedacht dass die Rakete in
mein Haus fliegt das ist eine normale
Wohngegend hier gibt es keine
militärischen Einrichtungen die Ukraine
hat die bislang schwerste Angriffswelle
in diesem Jahr erlebt mit entsetzlich
vielen Opfern in der Stadt niepro aber
auch die Infrastruktur wurde erneut
attackiert die Folge Strom Engpässe in
vielen Landesteilen das russische
Verteidigungsministerium hat die
Angriffswelle bestätigt militärische
Ziele und Energie Systeme sein getroffen
worden kein Wort aber zur verheerenden
Attacke auf Zivilisten
im braunkohledorf lützerath hat die
Polizei ihre Räumungsarbeiten
abgeschlossen auf dem Gelände befinden
sich nur noch die beiden klimaaktivisten
die sich seit Tagen in einem Tunnel
verschanzt haben die Abrissarbeiten
gingen heute weiter und kamen schnell
voran die meisten Gebäude stehen schon
nicht mehr bei der Großdemo gegen den
geplanten Kohleabbau kam es gestern zu
teils gewalttätigen Auseinandersetzungen
in Nepal ist ein Flugzeug kurz vor der
geplanten Landung abgestürzt an
bordwaren 68 Passagiere und vier
Besatzungsmitglieder offenbar gab es
keine Überlebenden gestartet in der
nepalesischen Hauptstadt Kathmandu war
die Maschine unterwegs nach pokera beim
Landeanflug zum neuen Flughafen dort
stürzte sie in eine Schlucht mitten in
der Stadt Axel Konrad
die dramatischen Sekunden vor dem
Absturz das Flugzeug kippt nach links
dann die Explosion
der Absturz in eine Schlucht zwischen
den Wohngebieten als Erster am Unfallort
die Anwohner viele Schaulustige
Löschversuche mit dem Gartenschlauch
mit Seilen werden die Opfer aus den
Trümmern und aus der Schlucht gezogen 72
Menschen waren an Bord darunter 15
Ausländer unter anderem aus Frankreich
Irland Australien und Russland überlebt
hat offenbar niemand
pokerei ist die zweitgrößte Stadt Nepals
und liegt im Herzen des Landes sie ist
beliebter Ausgangsort von Touristen für
Trekkingtouren ins anapurnergebirge
immer wieder kommt es in Nepal zu
Flugzeugabstürzen durch die Berge
wechseln häufig die Flugbedingungen
dementsprechend ist das Fliegen dort
sehr anspruchsvoll im Himalaya und die
Piloten brauchen eine sehr gute
Ausbildung und die Flugzeuge müssen
natürlich erstklassig gewartet sein und
an beiden scheint es im Nepal
kontinuierlich zu haben
Abflugort in Kathmandu drängen
Angehörige auf Informationen die zwei
motorige Turboprop ATR 72 der
einheimischen Yeti Airline war 15 Jahre
alt dieser Typ wird vor allem für
Kurzstreckenflüge genutzt in Pokémon
Arbeiten wegen Dunkelheit unterbrochen
werden noch wurden nicht alle Opfer
gefunden
Sturm vor allem an den Küsten und
ergiebiger Regen fast überall immer mehr
Regionen in Deutschland kämpfen mit den
Folgen der Unwetter nördlich von
Frankfurt am Main ist die eigentliche
beschauliche Nidder so stark über die
Ufer getreten dass nur noch Züge auf dem
Dampf Vorankommen an der Mosel bereiten
sich Helfer und Anwohner mit Sandsäcken
auf weitere Wassermassen vor
jetzt zum Sport am Sonntag mit dir
Christian und alles im Schnelldurchgang
zwei Wochen vor Beginn der
Weltmeisterschaften in St Moritz feiern
die Deutschen bobfahrerinnen auch beim
Weltcup in Altenberg erneut einen
dreifach Drehung für zweier Frauenpower
im Eiskanal der Höhepunkt des
wintersporttages
Lisa buckwitz rechts holt mit Kira
Lipperheide ihren ersten Weltcupsieg als
Pilotin eine Überraschung im Erzgebirge
die die 28-Jährige wenig euphorisch
kommentiert es hätte vielleicht noch
etwas besser sein können ihre Rennen
nicht perfekt die tollen Startzeiten
sind das große Plus des Duos Platz zwei
für karlikifig Dritte Olympiasiegerin
Laura Nolte mit Lena neunecker
Doppelsieg mit Tränen ganz ergriffen ist
Rodlerin Anna Bereiter über ihren
triumphensigula Lettland wo sie 2020
schwer gestürzt war es sei für sie eine
Qual gewesen an diesem Ort zu sein sie
habe ihr Herz in die Hand genommen sagt
die Olympia zweite
der Weltcup wird gleichzeitig als
Europameisterschaft gewertet den Titel
sichert sie sich vor der Jana eidberger
und gewinnt auch noch Silber mit der
Mixed-Staffel hinter Lettland
Freude überrang 2 skispringerin Selina
Freitag genießt die beste
weltcupplatzierung ihrer Karriere nach
Sprüngen über 98 und 98,5 Meter sehr
knapp die Entscheidung in Sao Japan Eva
pinkelnig aus Österreich die führenden
Weltcup ist nur 1,3 Punkte besser
es geht wieder los für segestern Boris
Hermann diesmal mit seinem Team Alicia
das unter deutscher flaggefährt einmal
um die Welt beim oschenholz am
Nachmittag Start in Alicante erste
Etappe Richtung Kapverden insgesamt
liegen 32.000 Seemeilen vor den fünf
groß ein halbes Jahr auf dem Meer die
große Herausforderung der Kampf mit
hohen Wellen und eisiger Kälte und wenn
alles gut geht Rückkehr im Juli im Genua
danke Kristin wir haben noch die
Wetteraussichten und die gehen so morgen
im Westen erneut Regen oberhalb von etwa
300 Metern Schnee in der Mitte und im
Südwesten im Flachland einzelne
Sturmböen bei maximal drei bis acht Grad
unsere einschaltempfehlung für 21 Uhr
heißt heute journal mit Christian
Sievers wir sehen uns wenn Sie mögen
morgen wieder jetzt weiter ins
ZDF-Hauptstadtstudio zu Berlin direkt
und Chuck unter Lavendel